so let's get ourselves the very latest
on the crisis from on the ground uh
joining me from the eastern ukrainian
city of la viv alistair bunkel from the
southern port city of odessa nick martin
and in the polish capital warsaw of
course a hub for refugees fleeing the
conflict lisa holland good to see all of
you but alistair let's let let's turn to
you first for an overview of what we
have seen overnight i mean certainly the
latest mod briefing suggesting okay it
may be a slow advance but the russians
do continue to encircle kiev
yeah i think that's absolutely right um
they have in their morning updates that
sense of infamous column outside of kiev
of around 40 kilometers long that got
bogged down for many days well now that
the weather has cleared a little bit and
new satellite imagery uh has been
obtained it looks as though that column
has dispersed somewhat um which means
the russians have probably successfully
taken out
some of the the vehicles within it and
redistributed them
around the ukrainian capital nonetheless
uh the ukrainian armed forces have done
a very very good job at not only slowing
that column down but destroying many of
the vehicles within it but it speaks
really to what looks to be the russian
strategy at the moment and that is to
encircle the capital as it has done uh
with other cities like mario paul and
probably strangle it over a number of
days and use um rather than ground
forces that have been pretty ineffective
thus far things like artillery barrages
to to pummel towns and cities into
submission and
air raid sirens in the middle of the
night waking us up here and across
the country as the fear of more russian
airstrikes still persists
and so the the grinding war goes on but
it is a grinding war that is seeing
russia slowly advancing for now despite
uh the very brave ukrainian resistance
alastair thank you uh well let's move on
to odessa where we'll find nick martin
of course nick odessa clearly a
strategic target for the russians but
the people where you are at preparing
for them
yeah that's right i mean odessa is and
always has been high on the list for
vladimir putin it is a key port on the
black sea it used to be the jewel in the
crown of the soviet union and it would
be strategically and militarily a very
key city for vladimir putin and his
military forces to seize because it
would effectively cut off ukraine from
the sea and it would give the russians a
lot more power of what comes in and out
of this country we know that there is
fighting uh two or so hours up the road
uh east mikalaya they've been constantly
shelling that city for a few days now
and we know that there has been shelling
overnight that again another key uh port
city and so that effort to try and cut
off from the black sea is well underway
and they are
preparing unfortunately for a similar
thing here at odessa yesterday we were
down on the beaches watching um
volunteers filling sandbags they filled
350 000 of them in the last two weeks
and they are now fortifying
shop fronts and buildings and cultural
sites the opera house and there are
barricades on all of the streets those
big iron crosses hedgehogs that are
designed to stop the flow of tanks
coming down the street there are
soldiers everywhere and they are uh very
resilient they're saying that the
russians won't even get here i spoke to
an old man on the street yesterday who
said we'll send the russians back but
the fact is that odessa is on vladimir
putin's list and we know that the
fighting and the shelling is getting
closer and
people here are just bracing themselves
you're in a humanitarian aid station
yesterday
a place that just three weeks ago was a
kind of trendy food hall is now
preparing itself to bring casualties
food first aid kits when we were filming
the air raid sirens went off we were
ushered down into the basement and a
load of young people volunteers sat
there for about half an hour listening
to a guy play on the guitar a girl in
the corner was crying and
there's a lot of uncertainty here
and so this city i have to say this
morning
is very quiet but when you take a walk
around it is quite unbelievable to see
the barricades and the fortifications
and the troops and the tanks uh
preparing for what might come to odessa
potentially in the next few days there
were unconfirmed reports of russian
warships just off the coast here in the
black sea there some sightings from
western crimea not far from here had
suggested that they'd seen amphibious
boats off the coast that could suggest
that the russian army would mount an
assault from the beaches here which is
why they are being very cautious and
they're looking out to the black sea
wondering whether those russian forces
will attack from there or possibly from
the east
let's leave odessa for now and head over
the the polish border to warsaw we will
find lisa holland and lisa we were
speaking yesterday about the the huge
number of refugees that are pouring over
the border and the problems that that's
creating i suspect that in the 24 hour
since we last spoke well things haven't
gotten any better
no and in fact whilst there's absolutely
no doubt at all that there is genuinely
a warm welcome here and real real
empathy for what uh people are going
through those who fled across the border
the authorities are not trying to dress
it up as anything else other than the
fact that they are under a huge amount
of pressure in fact the mayor has been
tweeting saying uh things are getting
more and more difficult by the day and
that just about sums it up really this
is not a crisis that's kind of happened
and now they're dealing with the
aftermath this is ongoing this is an
emergency
and more and more people are arriving
almost kind of difficult to keep track
of the numbers but we know that you know
two and a half million people have uh
poured over the borders into
neighbouring countries and the lion's
share have come here to poland and what
that means is that along with volunteers
and the authorities in warsaw they need
to literally kind of pick up the pieces
of people who are getting off trains and
buses absolutely exhausted across on the
border you've got people kind of coming
over on cars
walking over so they they literally kind
of need something to eat something to
drink somewhere to sleep so that's kind
of the initial emergency couple of days
but then it's only just begun because
most of the people that i've been
talking to here don't want to go on to
another country it's not like a kind of
normal migration crisis where people say
right i want to kind of rebuild my life
and end up in the uk because i've got
relatives there or something like that
some people of course do have relatives
but most people just kind of want to
stay put here so they can get back home
as quickly as possible and the key thing
of course is that kind of as we all know
by now the um the men the husbands the
brothers the uh the the fathers they've
stayed behind so women and children here
this is a women and children refugee
crisis uh they all want to sort of get
back home and they're absolutely frantic
and worried sick and just trying to get
a text message or something which says
to them look i'm okay our house is okay
we've spoken to lots of people who've
said look i've had a message to say you
know my house is gone i can't get hold
of my husband my husband's in the army
etc etc it goes on and on and on and so
you know in a nutshell the authorities
here having to kind of pick up the
pieces with all of that to the point now
that there's talk of trying to bus
people to other cities and inevitably
there'll be questions from the polish
government about what the rest of europe
can also do now to support poland
lisa holland in war sonic martin odessa
and of course alster bunker in levitt
thank you all